Географія українського експорту змінюється.
За даними Держстату, Росія вперше втратила статус головного торговельного партнера.
За підсумками минулого року, Україна найбільше експортувала до Китаю та Польщі.
При цьому торгівля з ЄС значно сповільнилася. Що продає Україна і що заважає експорту?
2019 року експорт товарів з України становив 50 мільярдів доларів.
Це майже на 6 відсотків більше, ніж 2018-го.
Україна традиційно найбільше продає сировини та аграрної продукції.
Кукурудза, пшениця, соняшникова олія, добрива, руда, металопрокат,
частини до залізничних локомотивів і таке інше.
Але все це, як правило, не готові товари, а лише сировина для них.
Тож додана вартість не створюється.
Хоча є потенціал для виробництва кораблів і літаків, обладнання для газовидобувної галузі
та іншого машинобудування, ліків та готових продуктів харчування.
Точних прогнозів щодо того, які наслідки для економіки України,
зокрема експорту, матиме пандемія коронавірусу, наразі немає.
Втрати експортерів залежатимуть від жорсткості карантинних заходів
і від того, чи буде друга хвиля захворювання.
За оцінками аналітиків, попит на продовольчі товари все одно залишатиметься.
Приміром, коли сталася світова економічна криза 2009 року,
експорт України впав на 40 відсотків.
Але якщо розглядати тільки аграрний сектор, то падіння було лише на 12 відсотків.
Нині ж, за підсумками квітня, Україна відправила за кордон
рекордну кількість соняшникової олії - 717 тисяч тонн.
Жоден з виробників не зупинив роботу.
Третина всього аграрного експорту - це саме масложирова продукція.
Крім того, у цьому маркетинговому році, який розпочався 1 липня 2019-го,
Україна вже експортувала понад 52 мільйони тонн зерна та зернобобових.
Це на 18 відсотків більше, ніж станом на кінець травня минулого року.
А от експорт української "молочки" за останні чотири місяці
скоротився на 26 відсотків по всіх категоріях молочних товарів.
При цьому імпорт зріс аж на 156 відсотків.
Після успішного березня у квітні Україна експортувала удвічі менше цукру.
А загалом за вісім місяців нинішнього маркетингового року
експорт скоротився майже в чотири рази.
За словами аналітиків "Укрцукру", більшість українських ринків зайняв російський цукор,
зокрема через зручну логістику до країн Середньої Азії.
Тоді як ціна українського виробника вища саме через витрати на транспортування.
Крім того, впливає і торговельна агресія Росії, зокрема заборона з боку РФ
транзиту її територією товарів українського походження до третіх країн.
Просування українського експорту на світові ринки стане одним із ключових показників
ефективності українських дипломатів, обіцяє прем’єр Денис Шмигаль.
За його словами, це буде своєрідна реформа дипломатичної служби.
Також перезапускається Рада експортерів та інвесторів для відкриття
нових ринків та збільшення українського експорту.
Торгівля товарами з ЄС значно сповільнилася.
І одне з головних завдань - подальше полегшення правил торгівлі з Євросоюзом,
зокрема збільшення безмитних тарифних квот для України,
а також усунення нетарифних бар’єрів для торгівлі.
Це коли потрібно надавати якісь документи або пройти додаткову експертизу.
Приміром, санітарні заходи, технічне регулювання, митні процедури і так далі.
За словами аналітиків Реанімаційного пакету реформ,
українські експортери мають суттєві проблеми з польськими дозволами
на транзит та доставку товарів автомобільним транспортом.
Подібні бар’єри, а також адаптація законодавства до стандартів Євросоюзу
- нині найбільше обмеження торгівлі з ЄС.